اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها مجموعه من الملفات
هذا المساء وفي عناوينها
ما الاسباب الحقيقيه وراء مهاجمه قائد
مجموعه فاجنر للقياده العسكريه الروسيه
مناوره لتحقيق مكاسب داخليه ام انها تعكس
عمق الخلافات بين قيادات بوتين في الميدان
اتهامات مبطنه بين التيار الوطني وميليشيا
حزب الله استقطاب داخلي ام نهايه تحالف
وفي ملفنا الثالث للنقاش هل يتسبب النزاع
بين قياده الاخوان في جبهتي اسطنبول
ولندنا في تقسيم التنظيم
ونحييكم الى تفاصيل لاول مره تبرز
الخلافات علنيه وعنيفه بين رئيس مجموعه
وبين رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه
ووزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو بريكوجين
شانما وصف بالهجوم الشارع الذي وجهه بشكل
صريح وبالاسم ضد وزير الدفاع ورئيس هيئه
الاركان والتهمها او اتهمهما بالخيانه
لحرمان عناصره من الضخائر وفق قوله بل ورد
على وزاره الدفاع التي رفع تصريحاته بان
صعد اكثر وطلب بضغط شعبي على الجيش
لتسليمه ضخائر وقبل تصريح الاخير لقائد
فاغنر فالندات وزاره الدفاع اتهاماته
وذكرت بالارقام سلمته لعناصره من الذخائر
كما وعدت بتسليم جميع طلبات الذخيره التي
تحتاجها مسمتها بالوحدات المتطوعه في
اشاره الى مقاتل فاجنر في الايام المقبله
سبق له ان انتقد وفي اكثر من مره في
الواقع القياده العليا الروسيه ولكن يبدو
ان هذا الهجوم على رئيس الاركان ووزير
الدفاع الشخصيتان الرئيسيتان في النظام
الروسي يعد تصعيدا وفق الوكاله الفرنسيه
التي اضافت ان الامر يبدو تنافسا على
الارض
الاوكرانيين او على ارض الاوكرانيين بين
هذه الشخصيات الثلاثه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من كوبنهاجن
الكاتب المتخصص في شؤون روسيا واسيا
الوسطى سامر الياس اهلا بك من موسكو
المحلله السياسي اهلا بكم ضيفاي الكريمين
واسم حالي ان ابدا من موسكو معيني في
الواقع كما ذكرنا في مقدمه هذا الملف ليست
بالمره الاولى التي تنشر او يكون هناك
حديث عن خلافات بين قائد باغنير وجيش
الروسي ولكن هذه المره كانت تصريحاته
مباشره وقويه كما وصفها البعض وصف حتى
وزير الدفاع الروسي بالخائن بما انه لم
يسلمه الذخائر اللازمه وتحدث عن برقراطيه
قاتله في الجيش الروسي ما الاسباب
الحقيقيه بحسب قراءتك من وراء هذه
التصريحات
تحيه لكريم ولصدر المشاهدين الوالدين
اولا لابد من التذكير بان شركه واغنر لا
تعتمد على يعني قاعده قانونيه في روسيا
وهي شركه خاصه ولم يتم تقنينها او شرعنتها
قانونيا
ودائما كان المسؤولون الروسي يشعرون الى
ان الحكومه والسلطات بوجه عام في روسيا
لعلاقه لها بهذه الشركه التي طبعا تتصرف
حسب كما تشاء ان صح التعبير وبالمناسبه
اكد ذلك
انها تتصرف كما تشاقت يستوقفك البعض لانه
هذا ما تقوله روسيا الرسميه في حين ان
هناك معلومات اخرى تقول بانه اما وزاره
الداخليه او الكريملين مباشره هو الذي
يمول يشرف يتحكم في هذه المجموعه فقد
تعليق على حضرتك
تعليقي بسيط ليس هناك من اي ادله على
تمويل هذه الشركه من قبل الحكومه او من
قبل اي جهه رسميه او غير رسميه لان
هو رجل اعمال كبير ولديه ما يكفي من المال
ليتولى تمويل
الجيش طبعا بالتنسيق ربما مع شركائه الذين
ايضا هم اعدادهم غير قليل هذا اولا ثانيا
طبعا هذه الانتقادات كانت تسمع قبل ذلك
قبل هذه الايام عده مرات ووضح تماما ان
شركته
الهدف الرئيسي من هذه التصريخات هو اللي
يسرق النصر من ايديهم لانه هم لعبوا دورا
اساسيا مثلا في السيطره على سوليدار التي
سبقت معركتها معركه بخموت الحاليه
وبالتالي يعني ربما هناك غضب مبطن
صاحب الشركه وليد الشارقه كل وعناصرها بان
هناك نقص في زخائر ولكن انا لا اعتقد بان
هذا الخلاف ربما يثير اي او يخلق اي مشكله
بالنسبه للكريملين والحقيقه ان هناك شعارا
واحدا الان مثل ما كان ايام الحرب
العالميه الثانيه التي سميت في الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق بالحرب الوطنيه العظمى
كان هذا الشعار يقول كل شيء من اجل الجبهه
وكل شيء من اجل النصر وهذا يعني انه مهما
اختلف مثلا قائد مجموعه ووزاره الدفاع الا
انهما يطمحان لتحقيق النسب ربما بطرق
مختلفه وهذا ما ترحب به القياده الروسيه
رغم انه هذه الخلافات لن تؤثر على الارض
ولكنها تطرح اسئله كثيره حضرتك ارجعت هذه
الانتقادات الى حب كل طرف وبتحديد قائد
فاغنير الى نسب الفوز ما رايك استاذ سامر
تحيه طيبه لك استاذه ريم بدايه ولزميل
والصديق العزيز الجاني من موسكو الساده
المشاهدين انا لا اتفق بالمطلق مع هذا
الطرح الذي طرحه استاذنا الفقيني بطبيعه
الحال يمكن اذا كان هناك مشكلات بين هذين
الطرفين وكل طرف يعمل بشكل كما يريد هناك
فوضى استراتيجيه كبيره هي التي تسببت على
الاقل بالنكسات الكبيره التي منيت بها
روسيا في الجبل الاوكرانيه منذ بدايه
الحرب في 24 فبراير حتى الان الجانب
الفاجنر لم يشارك بدايه في هذه الحرب
الوزاره الدفاع الروسيه قررت الاستغناء
عنهم وهناك مجموعه من مرتزقه والمجموعات
العسكريه او شبه العسكريه التي شاركت في
البدايه وسعه وزاره الدفاع الى تكرار
تجربه باغنر بطرق اخرى بالاستغناء عن طباخ
بوتين
وكذلك استعانت بمجموعه من القوات الخاصه
الشيشانيه عندما فشلت كل هذه المحاولات
بعد الانسحاب من محيط كيب والتركيز على
ايضا لم يتم الاستعانه بهم لكن لاحقا في
المعارك في سفر وغيرها بدات الاستعانه
بشكل كبير بقوات فاجنر العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه حتى الان تم تغيير اكثر من ست
رؤساء بهذه العمليه العسكريه هي سابقه
حقيقه انتقادات بريغوجين رجل الاعمال
الكبير في روسيا لوزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان ولكن الخلافات ايضا كانت سابقه
منذ شهر سبتمبر الماضي وجه بريجوجن
انتقادات كبيره لالكسندر لابين الذي كان
قائدا
قوات الوسطى في دنيتك
ولاحقا تم اقالته ترددت انباء انه تم
اقالته ولكن
حسم هذا الموضوع باتجاه ترقيه الكسندر
لابين ليكون قائدا بقوات الاركان البريه
المشكله حقيقيه بان هناك تنافسا كبيرا بين
جنرالات وزاره الدفاع هذه المشكله
بالمناسبه لم نلحظها اثناء تولي سيرافيكا
قياده العمليه العسكريه واضح تماما ان
هناك عدد تيارات في داخل وزاره الدفاع
والتيلي كريم لان وفي
النخبه القريبه من بوتا التي تنحاز الى
جوارب وهناك نخبه ثانيه تنحاز لهزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وتريد المحافظه على نفس
التوازنات السابقه وهي ان مجموعه باجنا
لعمليات عسكريه خارجيه ويجب عدم المساس
بدور وزاره الدفاع وفي الجيش الروسي
كمؤسسه كمؤسسه
المحافظه على الامن والدفاع لان الانتقاد
وزاره الجيش والمقاتلين والجنرالات يعرض
صاحبه للحبس ثمان سنوات بين مشاهدنا قديره
بريغوجين يوجهان للانتقادات جوزيفا لوزاره
الدفاع واليوم
استاذ سامر بانه هناك صراع على الارض بين
اجنرالات وبين مجموعه فاجنر بقائ
دها السيد
واذا فعلا كانت هناك تجذبات وكانت هناك
خلافات عميقه لن تساعد في استمراريه هذه
العمليه العسكريه كما تسميها روسيا لمن
ستكون الغلبه كيف سيفصل الكريم
ببساطه شديده يمكنني الرد على هذا السؤال
كون زميلي ذكر السيد سورفيكم وقال انه لم
يكنر مش مشاكل معه لا شيء فيما يتعلق
بتزويد
بالذخائر ولكن هناك امر مهم اخر وهو ان
الرئيس بوتين منذ عده اسابيع غير او بدل
سورابيكا وعين لهذا المنصب القائد العام
لكل القوات التي تحارب في الجبهات
الاوكرانيه برئيس هيئه الاركان العامه
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه
انما يدل على ثقه الرئيس الروسي بوزاره
الدفاع
لكونها تتحمل ربما او تلعب دورا رئيسيا في
المعارك التي ربما تجري الان في مختلف
الجبهات الاوكرانيه ولكن هذا لا يعني هذا
التعيين الجديد بمناسبه ساره نائبا
لكن هذا التعيين ويعني هذا الامر بشكل عام
لا يقلل من اهميه في المعارك القادمه وهذا
يعني ان الرئيس بوتين ربما يحاول ان يحافظ
على نوع من التوازن لكن في نفس الوقت
الاولويه لوزاره الدفاع ونهايه الاركان
العامه لكونهما ربما يتوليان رئاسه اول
اشراف على السير المعارك التي تدور فيها
صحيح هو حتى من يراقب العمليه العسكريه لا
يقلل ابدا من دور واهميه هذه المجموعه رغم
كل الانتقادات في الواقع حتى انها سميت
الورقه الرابحه لموسكو ولكن استاذ سامر هل
تعتقد بان قائد فاغنر عينه على المكاسب
على الارض او ان عينه على المنصب لان
البعض قال بانه وكانه يحاول ان يفرض نفسه
على وزاره الدفاع وان يدافع المنصب هناك
هل هذا وارد انا اعتقد بان يطمح الى
التقرب اكثر من الرئيس بلادي مربوطين ولعب
دور اكبر في المعادله السياسيه الداخليه
في روسيا عبره هذه التجاذبات وعبره اثبات
بانه كان الطرف الاساسي المساهم في
الانتصارات وان اي نكسه للجيش الروسي
ولقوات الروسيه المقاتله في دينيسكو في
اوكرانيا لم تتم بسبب استخدام قوات فاجنر
اهميه قوات فاجنر بالنسبه لوزاره الدفاع
هي اهميه كبيره اجبرتها في ال 13 يناير
الماضي من تغيير البيان الاساسي عندما تم
تحرير بلده سوليدار وحينها لم يتم الاشاره
الى الجهود التي قام بها
وفي المساء تم تعديل هذا البيان وقالوا
اشادت وزاره الدفاع بالدور المهم
لمقاتليه فاجنر في العمليات عمليات تحرير
سريدار الدوري المهم لفاجنر يكمن ربما في
ان هذه المؤسسات تقدم الكثير المئات من
القتلى يوميا من اجل تحقيق تقدم ولو كان
بطيئا للقوات الروسيه هم يتقدمون القتال
وبموجات كبيره من اجل اضعاف الجبهه
الاوكرانيه للتقدم ايا كان الثمن لاحقا
ياتي جيش الروسي ويقدم ويتقدم في هذه
الساحه النقطه الثانيه المهمه هي ان ايضا
قوات تحصل على تمويلها وتحصل على الاسلحه
بالتاكيد من وزاره الدفاع لانه لا يمكن ان
تكون هناك شركه عسكريه خاصه تملك صواريخ
مضاده للطائرات تملك طائرات مسيره
تقول ليس بالكميه الكافيه
المشكله اذا سمحت لي ضمن المشكله الكبيره
التي تعاني منها روسيا وتعاني منها
اوكرانيا ايضا وهي قله الذخائر بسبب
الاستخدام الكثيف لهذه الدقائق منذ نحو
عام في المعارك لذلك هناك ازمه كبيره
يتعرض لها الجيش الروسي فاجنا وكذلك
الاوكرانيون والغرب يسعى لحل مشكله
الاوكرانيين وبوت الناشده
الصناعات العسكريه من اجل زياده الذخائر
المطلوبه في المعركه والتي ستكون حاسمه
بالمناسبه في تحديد من هو الطرف المنتصف
الناضله للبلدين ولكن سيد يفكيني هل تراك
ضيفي بان تصريحات قائد فاغنر للتقرب من
بوتين لفرض اسمه ونفسه ام ان عينه على
منصب وزاري كما يرى البعض وحتى البعض في
الداخل الروسي
اولا
ليس بحاجه الى التقرب اكثر الى بوتين لانه
هو اصلا كان قريبا جدا منه وبالمناسبه
تسميته بطباخ بوتين غير صحيحه لانه حسب
قوله قول بريجوجل نفسه وقول بعض مصادر
اخرى لم يطبخ ابدا وهذا ليس اختصاصه انما
هو صاحب المطاعم وهو كان يؤمن الغذاء
الكثير
بعد صورته الشهيره التي كان يقدم فيها
طبقا لبوتين
نعم هذا صحيح ولكن تقديم طبقه الى بوتين
لا يعني انه كان يحضر هذه الطبقه وهذا
ربما دليله بالفعل على تقرب منه نعم نعم
ولكن لم تجبني عن التفصيل ان كانك تعليق
اولا باختصار شديد قبل اعاده الكلمه لضيفه
يعني اعتقد بان موضوع هو طبيعي صاحب شركات
كبيره لكن تقرب من بوتين انسبه الى انه
حتى الان تم تكريم معظم الجنرالات الذين
خاضوا الحرب والذين قدموا للعمليه
العسكريه ولكن حتى الان لم يلتقي بوتين
رسميا
منذ بدايه الحرب على اوكرانيا هذا من جانب
لم يتم منحه اي وسام رغم ان كثيرا من
الجرارات وغيرهم مثل رمضان قدير رفع سبيل
المثال تم مكافاته بوسام ولقاء بوتين معه
حتى الان لم يلتقي مع بوتين حسب المثبت
والرسمي منذ بدايه الحرب حتى الان
قادر على ان يكون اسما حامل لم من بين
المناصب الوزريه في حكومه بوتين او هذا
المستبعد
ربما انا لا استبعد مثل هذا التحول ولكن
تعليق بسيطه على ما قاله زميله الان
بريجوجن لم يمدح ولم يقلد اي وسام او اي
يعني لم يكرم كما قال زميله لسبب بسيط
واحد وهو السبب الذي ذكرته في البدايه
الشركه ليس لديها وضع قانون رسمي فبعد ان
تنال هذه الشركه على يعني بعد ما يتم
تقنينها وشرعاناتها بطبيعه الحال سوف
يتعاملون مع بريجوجن كالشخص رسمي وهذا
يعني انه ربما سوف يستحق يمنح في النهايه
الامر
مجموعه صحيح ولكن لا يمكن لهذه المجموعه
ان يكون لها وضع رسمي غير معلن
لا وضع الرسمي غير مولد نحن لا نعرف ذلك
يمكننا فقط ان نعتمد على تشريبات بهذا
الشان انا لا اعتقد بان لديها اي وضع رسمي
لانه من حيث المنطقه الرئيس بوتين هو
قانوني اختصاص قانوني وهو يعرف القوانين
ويعرف كيف يجب التعامل مع يعني
لانه هذه المزرعه صحيح ولكن لان هذه
المجموعه كذلك لديها او سلطت عليها عقوبات
من الاتحاد الاوروبي باختصار شديد وشديد
جدا استاذ سامر تفضل لانه انتهيت هذا
بوتين ان تبقى فقط اطار عملها في الخارج
لخدمه اجنده والرجال الاعمال المقربين فيه
كما هو الحال والتقارير التي تقول بانهم
عملوا في سوريا وليبيا ونحو 30 بلدا حول
العالم من ضمنها بلدان في افريقيا بات
وضعها واضحا للحصول على ثروات وخدمه اجنده
الكرملين في هذه البلدان طيب على كل سنبقى
في متابعه هذه المجموعه
تابعنا تطورات هذه الحرب شكرا جزيلا لكما
من كوبنهاجن الكاتب المتخصص في شؤون روسيا
واسيا الوسطى سامر الياس ومن موسكو يافقي
المحلل السياسي شكرا جزيلا